a special delivery of a capsule to the
australian outback
and this one came hurtling down from
space
and it may contain some answers to help
us to understand the origins of our
solar system
and how life began
this is the end of the hayabusa 2 probes
mission
that was sent to the 4.6 billion year
old asteroid ryogu
to collect samples of the rock
it had blasted off from japan in
december 2014
before reaching the asteroid in june
2018.
it touched down twice on the asteroid
ryogu
once in february last year when it fired
a pellet
at the surface of the rock to kick up
debris
it landed again five months later to
collect dust and rock from under the
surface
making it the first probe ever to
achieve this
this is the moment the team of
researchers realized the capsule would
safely return home
to earth japan's aerospace exploration
agency confirmed the capsule had
successfully separated from a hayabusa
too
it says this was a challenging operation
the required precision control
220 000 kilometers from earth
it had traveled much farther about
300 million kilometers having first
orbited the sun for three years
space enthusiasts in tokyo reacted to
this news
i heard that if the separation did not
work hayabusa itself would crash into
the earth
i'm really glad that it was successfully
released my heart was beating a bit
faster when i was watching
with japanese technology hayabusa 2 went
to a distant asteroid and came back
safely
i think it has the potential to prove
how advanced japanese technology is
scientists say they will analyze the
organic materials that come from the
subsurface of the asteroid
it could be in the same state it was
when the solar system first formed
they say they know organic material is
the origins of life but they still don't
know
how but the hayabusa ii probe and its
cargo
may provide some answers laura about a
manly al jazeera